genau genau genau dass man spaß die beim
it mitspielen kann
leute sei willkommen zu einer
wunderbaren games und wir werden uns
heute ein bisschen pipi master gegeben
ein paar leute kaputt hauen und sagen
wir das mittelalter was wird es von
anfangs was war das für ein ansatz für
timing das mal hier wieder ins mal in
mein haus kind sogar ein reagieren nicht
vorher wieder nicht weil ich schwöre ich
habe ein leben kaputt alter leute da
wird es dort
ich kann mir hier meine haus route und
ihr snack ich da drüben noch ein
bisschen was zusammen rund dann kommt er
also muss dazu wissen ich war nicht ist
naja ist noch nicht abgefahren
er ist er so repp erfahren erst rapper
sein
minecraft scherrer ist eines klar er hat
sich entschieden jetzt sein minecraft
und sein rapture zu trennen
eine coole sache um seinen
zuschauerzahlen noch gezielter das genau
das zu geben was sie wollen und das
feiere ich deswegen habe ich immer die
beschreibung gepackt weil mich und liebe
ich auch in der beschreibung ist wer ihm
immer ein bisschen ersten projekt ihr
wundert euch vielleicht wieso es auf
meinem channel ein video gibt wo ich
sage jetzt wird alles ein pvp
auseinandergenommen passten sich das
daran dass wir hier in dieser aufnahme
mit veri um pvp sind und zweitens daran
dass dieser gute wert pvp wie gesagt in
der beschreibung ein verdammter nachbar
ist und alles auseinander nimmt
und ich kann ihn schaffen können ich
hinein dauert es schon mal ich hab ein
stein stein sind
muss also ein team oder du wirst du wir
kommen uns einfach zum bahnhof zu
bahnhof
ich habe im grünsten also ich hab mir
mal ein kaputtes nektar solltest du
nicht das thema ansprechen
danach so eher leute wir haben jetzt
schon zwei aufnahmen gemacht da gab es
hier damals und es kann dieser großen
ganzen darum dass ihr bestimmt diesen
typen kennt von und ich lese blatt
dieser typ ist so ein abartiges können
muss man spaß spielen kann
denn haben samen könnt ihr von mir haben
wollen wir nicht
und gott oh gott und ich hab auch und
diese dieser typ ist freudig gerannt
alter jeder typ wie so häufig gerannt
diese kaputt gehauen wir wollen dich
nicht verletzen
wenn du stirbst einfach weg alter stelle
mir vor serie life alternativ oder so
keine ahnung und mit deiner freundin und
die rutscht die hand ist erlischt
einfach okay ich versuche es gibt es
gibt noch ewig viele alter frozen pvp
gibt's ja ganz ehrlich wie dumm kann man
sein sein channel gefroren ist player
versus player der jungs lassen experten
wie macht jetzt extrem groß was ist im
boden gebracht ich wollte wegrennen
da hast du von uranus habe ich gar nicht
mag ich habe ihn so krass getroffen als
ich den locker gekillt und dann habe ich
im winter her gerannt
er plant einfach tnt und ich mag einfach
im boden konnte platz nacheinander
leute ich jetzt ein bisschen mein leben
und denken dann habe ich ihn auseinander
ich schwöre ich nehme auseinander
ich würde nie hätte die macher jolo wir
haben diesen niveaus köpfe der kann eh
nix wo ich mache schon wieder im boden
leute schaut euch die auf noch mal nicht
bug im boden hat ich konnte mich darauf
klar schaut man in die kommentare was
ich dagegen machen kann
alter und dann schreibt in die
kommentare ob ihr findet das der typ von
schlagmann gollum ist und das finde ich
würde so ein krasser gollum und vor
allem wie kann man als so ein richtiger
mensch sei nicht mein pornos dass der
immer irgendwie leute sehen die hübsch
sind oder so oder befinden können oder
aber noch nicht so einen hässlichen
vogel hätte es gibt auch so fest in
pornos
ich versuche diesen leak videos aber
irgendwie zu retten hätten die banken
herein wetten gott oh gott da nicht so
schlau so hinterher gehen ohne scheiß
ich habe mir so hat jetzt packt den
hammer aus ihr wichtig
leute ich komme nicht mehr aus
heute ist der lauffläche des verderbens
ist die domäne von geht immer wieder
dreckig geht jedoch damit den bogen
ganz ehrlich ich meine wie dumm kann man
sein nichts gegen die menschen aber das
jetzt mal so sagen was wird es die ip
vpn oder das auf jeden fall kriegt halt
erstmal zwei pfeiler kommt aber immer
noch wieder hier kein runder und schaut
dort an cat 135 du bist wahrscheinlich
ein mädchen nichts gegen mädchen aber
das war so einen sagen auf der pvp feld
ich gebe jetzt eine feine ich bin dem
wasserfall ich kann nicht so schnell
hoch kommen häufig liest nicht nur
höchst für behinderte mutter in höhe bis
mir doch fallen die fresse ballern
ja will ich da ist der fall
schlag machen dieser gollum auf dem klar
kommen
ihr müsst euch den man schon heute schau
dir mal ja schlecker rossmann und nicht
newborn sollen youtube ein
und die findet ja ja ich hab's ich hoffe
ich hab' ich habe mich hab ich hab' ich
habe das alter ich hab gedacht wurden
alte wie kleinliche kritik nichts zu
essen dann schaue ich momentan nur eine
schüssel fünf roth pilze und sieben
braun pilze beste leben alter schwimmer
pilz und snacken
ich liebe diese qualifiziert
kommentarseite kfd yapi schiesst aber
die isu diese stabil
ht alle kann extrem ab
warum ich meine rüstung aus schuhe und
schwert der ratings hat aber fast ganz
ehrlich ich habe so hart gegeben
noch voller leben kommt der amerikaner
ok ich würde sagen wenn ihr boss
konstellation hat sich verdammt lustig
war mit newslettern
lasst mich das wissen lässt ein leichter
schreibt in die kommentare und 3